it's my great pleasure to be here and
yeah it's a very good opportunity for me
to introduce the the recent work and so
so my previous background actually is
auditory neuroscience I would like to
briefly introduce why I got interested
in this topic because we know that in
order to neuroscience time is quite
important for example when you hear the
speech I'm producing of course time is
important you need to extract the
temporal structure from my speech and
your brain should follow the envelope of
the speech signals and producing and
then you can process and then you can't
stand what I'm talking about and our
previous work shows that not only that
our brain signals could actually track
the envelope of the speech signal but
also it's not just it's not just a
passively following it's kind of a doing
temporal organization of the incoming
auditory signals so in other ways our
previous work show that our brain
actually segment and the chunk the
incoming auditory input in an active way
to help us understand the auditory
signals so then I'm quite interested in
this wise because I am wondering whether
we can find a similar role of time in
vision so how about vision can we find
some critical role of time in vision and
of course there are a lot of work
showing that for example it's very
established than your own oscillation
mediate selective attention like pop
decimals lab they have showed that gamma
band synchronization between the high
errors and those sensory errors they can
help to achieve the selective attention
for example when the C and a they have
shows some gamma band synchronization
the stimulus at the the a location will
be selectively attended and the neural
responses were being cast and also there
are many many labs showing that neuron
oscillations plays greater role in
different cognitive functions and also
there are we also know that our brain is
not just a continuous processing thing
for example the Ferenc spiking
probability
were depend on the face of the local
field potential so they suggested that
I'll bring actually have some
concatenate kind of windows of
opportunity to come out and so neural
oscillation also reflect the rhythmic
temporal cortex and also rule for
Maryland's lab in France lab they show
that they show that in both behavior and
eg studies they found that actually
attention non sample stimulus
continuously but bris medically in ten
Hertz so these are backgrounds that
showing that time is also quite
important to envision because previous
people when people talking about vision
they are talking about space shape color
so now related to time but many works
show that time is also quite important
in vision so this is our start is
motivation and of course selective
attention is important for example when
you drive a car on the road in the car
in front of you it's the most important
thing you should many attend but but
certainly there are some other things
which is also quite important for
example there are dog maybe cross the
road and there are a passenger may also
cross the road and there are some
incoming cars in the future so you need
to allocate in some ways some
attentional resources to other maybe
tasking relevant items but how bring
tooth does this so we think attention
must be efficiently and flexible a
distributed over time and objects to
accommodate different tasks context and
we our hypothesis is temporal dimension
might be important to organize and
coordinate attentional allocations on
multiple visual objects so this is
something I'm gonna to talking about
today and we are interesting exploring
the temporal structures individual
attention and two parts first we want to
see whether we can see dynamics in
behavior individual attention in the
second part we use eg to try to
understand the neural dynamics in visual
attention so the first the first part is
done by this
in person whines Quinn zoom so he is my
former graduate student he's now at max
planck for postdoc and he's doing
spatial attention and also dr. Jung Hwan
he's doing like future attention priming
but today I'm just talking about Quinn's
work okay let's first see what's our
traditional view about our attentional
behavior so we have behavior every day
but basically we have a classical
sluggish view for the Henschel behavior
if you have watched that movie you will
know what I mean so which means that
although your neuron activities in your
brain it's quite fast we believe that
your behavior is not as fast as the
neural activity do and the PV behavior
is always sluggish and slow so that's
why we you look at the behavior results
in almost all the paper for example the
y-axis is the behavior bearment like
reaction time or the performance
accuracy you will see the overall
behavior performance is like the bar so
you just a compare the behavior means
under different conditions and not think
about time right or you can yes Mero the
behavior as a function of time but still
we think about in a sluggish merriment
so you may see some slowly developed
course in the behavior but recently
there are some other views so this is
our previous a perspective of a sluggish
behavior but now there is some other way
so maybe there are some hidden temporal
dynamics in the behavior and we can
narrow the behavior using a much finer
temporal scale like this way
so using this way from the behavior data
we can know whether we we really see
some faster dynamics and and there are
some two reason to work using this
time-resolved environment and they got
some interesting results they find that
actually behavior yes fluctuate as a
function of SOA so this means that our
behavior is not as sluggish at we think
before so this we just use a very
classical spatial pre queuing paradigm
so I just briefly introduce you
basically the subjects need to attend to
this two squares simultaneous
and then there will be a preview then
after some time the target will occur
either AG acute side or on Q side and
the subjects just discriminate the shape
of the target and by pressing a key and
then we recorded their reaction time so
that's it but the key parameters we
manipulated here is the time between the
Q and the target
we sample that in steps of 20
milliseconds so which means we use 50
Hertz sampling frequency to sample the
behavior let's see what we get
so this is our results and x-axis is a
cue to target time okay and the y-axis
is normalized that behavior merriments
and the different color just means
different cue and uncle so two
conditions and this is a classical
result so people replicate that for many
many years so people know this is right
but if you compare our results and
previous results you can see that they
are different although they share
something so the first thing we need to
do is we need to do something and try to
replicate the classical results and what
we find is that very interestingly if we
just extract the slow trends of our
moments we can replicate the previous
results so this suggested that classical
attentional effects actually can be
replicated in the slow trends of our
data and this makes a lot of sense
because classical merriments think they
kind of doing a sluggish measurement
that's why they can rap they are
replicating our slow trends then we
treat our time resolve the behavioral
results so remember this is a behavior
results we treated it as the brain
signals were recorded like egm EG and
we're doing a we did a time frequency
analysis of the behavior results and
this is what we found
so it's quite surprising that first we
find alpha pulses in the behavior time
courses and think this haven't been
found before in both what would the
target either happened in Q location on
Q location so the x-axis is their time
the y-axis is the frequency so you can
see some alpha pulses in the terror
and also we find that there are seems to
be your alternating ship between the
alpha palaces so they jumps between
these two locations remember we have to
square so this means alpha palaces will
jump from the cute from the cute an
uncute like alternative way so we try to
quantify the relationship between the
cure location uncle occasions so we're
just doing a subtraction so well it
might miners invalid and you can see
clearly the blue red blue red blue so
this means the switching between the
cute and uncle locations imposed laptop
visual fields and writer bright little
fields also we noticed that the Alpha
pulses seems to be modulated by a much
slower reason if you look at this way
you can see that the interval between
the blue and the interval between the
red are all kind of around 300
milliseconds so this suggested and 300
milliseconds correspond to a seat up and
reason so this indicate that the ARF up
house is modulated in a seated reason so
it got such hypothesis so the Alpha
pulses is fast and it's happening in
both cute and cute and there seems to be
a slow reason to modulate kind of a sea
hand to modulate the thing and then we
try to demonstrate whether there are
some relationship between the our finest
theta and we just a do alpha set up our
phase locking basically the result shows
yes so there are a power and the phase
locking relationship between the our
finest theta in behavior results and
people know that previous
electrophysiological recording or those
shoulders in the electrophysiology data
but here we show that in behavior data
so this matches very well and also this
suggests as theta reason actually
mediated Zartha pain process in time so
let me summarize the thing we find in
the behavior oscillations will coil
behavior oscillation because the
behavior results and it has shows some
reasons
so the typical attentional effects it's
in the slow frequency trend and there
seems to be a SATA banner reason so the
attention samples is to locations using
Seto reason like every 300 milliseconds
and within the location we think it's
alpha pout so 10 Hertz frequency but
what does this mean the Alpha are four
bands 10 Hertz it's a kind of processing
or to mean something if you look at
previous literature especially G L say
alpha band it's claimed that to be
inhibitory nature so when people attend
to the lab that is your field people
know that the contralateral Arfa
actually in kippot not enhanced so this
suggests we the Alpha pen doesn't mean
processing enhancing it means
attentional inhibition so back to our
results this is a summary of our results
so we need to attend both of these two
locations and first secure locations so
it's cute and then the attention will be
captured there by producing an
inhibitory alpha on the onkyo location
but attention will not be always there
they will shift to the uncured location
by producing hit betray artha at any
location and the reason is kind of a
seeder reason and using this way we can
wrap we can explain our behavior results
also this way we try the same way with
similar thing on the central cueing
paradigm so now it's not peripheral
cueing but the subjects need to attend
attend according to the central cue and
there will be 66 percent of Q validity
and we just redid the same same error
the reaction time and we find that slow
trend can replicate classical results
and if you do the same analysis we'll
find very similar things so this means
that it's a quiet kind of very general
phenomenon okay
and also our results suggested that our
behavioral results a knowledge is not a
flash in the zodavia it's a dynamic in
nature so the classical measurement just
Amero the tips of the iceberg in the
real behavior data and also our results
provide new perspective for behavior
performances okay
I'm gonna to type introduce the second
Bart neurodynamics individual attention
so this it this work is many done by
Jackie room so he's my future student
code supervised DeWitt song song we so
here we want to use eg to examine your
dynamics but one difficult is seeing in
eg is that for example you need to
attend to those two discs but using eg
is difficult to dissociate the signal
specific to the attend in an unattended
so we use a technique which core the
temporal response function so what does
this mean
so first I'm introduced the paradigm is
kristincole first there is an error cue
telling you which side you should attend
to for example here's to the to the left
and then there will be two discs have
occurred and you need to sustain
sustainability attend to like one disk
and because there will be a target
randomly occurring there and you just
yeah attend here 100% but the that here
is the luminance of the two discs we
actually modulate in time for five
seconds according to to Brandon and
independent am Sarah
so the luminance of this disk they were
just we just a generally generate a red
and temporal sequence II so the
luminance will modulate this way and
this way this disc will modulating
another way and they are independent and
we require the eg signals by doing a
linear regression ship between the EEG
signals and the time series we can
dissociate the which we could have a
response function so this actually
represents neuron impulse response means
that they can know from the same EEG
signals we can dissociate the response
specific to the attend a disk and
specific to the unattended disk and this
is a kind of impulse response which
means that it's a responses to each each
lumen and change in the signals and this
master actually has been used in the
auditory studies so this is our results
we find that yes you can you can sex
successfully get a TR every sip
this and this means that for each
luminance increment there will be a
tariff and when you shuffle the
relationship between the signals and the
sequence and signals you can now see the
thing and we again do a time frequency
analysis of the results we see the very
prominent alpha band but this is onset
we still can see some sustain alphabet
but it's not very clear here so then we
can compare the TRF between the Italian
and anger tenets so we do a subtraction
between these two conditions and again
we see a alpha inhibition so this means
when you compare the attend and our
tenth ERF the 10 shows the alpha
inhibition in the first 200 milliseconds
and it occurred happen in the prouder
channels so this it's really replicate
our previous behavior results remember
in the preview behavior results we also
find the initial alpha condition and
here we see the EEG signals still doing
an RFI inhibition but also interestingly
we see a reversal train here although
not significant so in the following 200
milliseconds there will be ours are
firing housement red this also
corresponds to our previous behavior
results so what does this mean this
means in the task even I asked subjects
to 100 completely attend to death disk
but attention doesn't do this way so
they will first adjusted do the attend
to the disk as you required in the first
200 milliseconds by producing an
inhibitory alpha on a tiny the one but
like after proximate 200 milliseconds
attention where intrinsically jump to
the unattended disk although is not
asked relevant by producing hibbett or
er feh on our 1081 so this is attention
of switching so it means that even when
attention is instructed to focus on the
eternities completely we still see the
intrinsic sequential sampling of visual
objects okay so next a question will be
whether the spatial temporal attentional
sampling pattern changes to a car Bearer
Tuscans test context so here we're using
the same Tiran but now we increase
q target to 75% which means that the
target will happen at 75 / us 75% of
probability the only cute disc and also
it has 25% probability to happen on
aren't any one and we just do the same
analysis and see the TRF and this is a
result will compare the 10 out and you
still can replicate that they show our
fahisha and you can see a very
significant alpha enhancement reversal
in the 200 milliseconds so this
suggested when the unattended it's a
little bit task relevant the attention
of switching just becomes much more
prominent we then decrease the Q
validity more by decreasing to 50%
probability
this means that target will be equally
possible to occur at this to disk and
that's what we find you can see that the
are fast switching becomes much much
more robust and temporally a pro loaded
so let me summarize this results this
means that when you pay 100% probability
to the a your attention kind of doing a
sequential sampling by creating a lot of
rotational chunks so you have a and then
you have a little bit like non
significant the B train here like this
way but when your Q validity decreased
you 70% 75% the B is the reversal trend
becomes more prominent and when they are
both possible you can see that the
attentional switching becomes more
prominent okay our final question is
that it observed the sequential attempt
temporal sampling specific to spatial
attention because in the previous week
with just a fix the two locations so
it's maybe just a focus on attention on
space but how about object space so we
do the same thing but now it's different
so we ask the subject to pay attention
to the disk but during the five seconds
they the luminance will change and also
at the same time they will wrong on the
screen like Randall E so the our spatial
location will not be fixed and we did
the same scene to destruct the TRF and
compare the attend and I'll attend we
see the very similar thing our frank
addition and the enhancement trend so
this is quite similar when when they are
not moving then they are there so this
suggested that the pattern we find is
not specific to spatial attention but
could also be extended to object based
attention okay let me summarize our
results so we show both behavior Deb
evidence and neuronal evidence so in
behavior we can see the behaviors latian
and alpha pulses switches between us two
locations in a theta reason and in the
neuronal dynamics dynamics we I used
here asked to examine the thing and we
also find that the attention seems to a
switch between these two locations by
using a inhibitory alpha pulses so this
suggested attention samples multiple
visual objects alternatively in time so
it's serial like something and the
tension of spatial temporal profile
adaptive changes to accommodate
different task statements when you when
when you changes the cube already you
can see the pattern actually changes it
also suggests that attention is dynamic
and rhythmic so this is a sequential
sampling of multiple visual order
objects go back to our original
motivation this suggested that yes you
need to many focus on this car but you
also sequentially allocate attentional
resources to other may be tusky relevant
targets in some way so and also you will
flexibly judges your attentional
sampling profile to accommodate
different context okay so I already
mentioned the behavior oscillation part
is many down back some seungkwan so yeah
and the EG part is by charging room and
i want to mention that my postdoc
loading he has using the trf2 trying to
extract the neuron responses from global
for global and local from the same
recording and he found that a global
actually initiate fast in the parietal
regions and this is a midi sorry i think
it the data looks quite interesting and
welcome to her poster and also want to
thank my
operators so fun fun week lap around the
eg star DS jong-hong my colleague we are
we are trying to create a computational
modeling to to model our results and
also I want to mention that roaming at
that Mouse College we actually have we
have some data showing that if we do fmi
we can also see the oscillation
therefore my signals using our same
paradigm and ok thank you very same
queue very much
[Applause]